wake me up
[Music]
again
a few things before we get started
please stay off yourself folks that'll
happen again keep table talk to a
minimum now who's ready for other people
are coming up to your house that talks
kids
what is up Austin Texas how you guys
doing
it's good to be here for other people a
dating show where we watch people date
uh we're gonna pick two names out of the
bucket and then we're gonna watch him
talk for 60 seconds in a date format
they're gonna try to be [ __ ] each
other
and then we're gonna roast them for
about
the rest of the time
undetermined lengths of time so it's
gonna be fun there's a lot of uh
equality amongst the Sexes tonight which
is good we don't want to have anyone
turn gay unless they want to
um but yeah if you want to turn gay
that's also a possibility that's fun uh
sometimes we force dudes to go on dates
together it's it's a great time it's
sexual abuse against men it's not really
sexual abuse
um yeah but it makes some noise if you
agree with that
yeah [ __ ] men they deserve it uh just
kidding it's very I love men in a
platonic way
um yes we're gonna make people date it's
gonna be great well we're not making
them it's we're gonna watch people date
uh we got another guest on the show to
balance out some of this autism some of
this incel energy that you're seeing
right now we got a real live woman a
human female and not only is she a
female but she's a very funny comedian
from Houston Texas please get up for
Rachel Faith McMillan and
[Applause]
then
Rachel how have you been so this year
I've been good it's been
22. hey guys
how's it going
what's your thoughts on the Austin
dating scene
oh yeah so yeah
the past year paddle board dates no way
go to Chuy's or cherry blacks maybe more
like sushi and Sushi and [ __ ] you know
oh
sign me up for that you got it is that a
Groupon or it is a Groupon
I actually thought about that I was like
what if and then being sober I also
thought what if there's a dating app for
sober people but it like like the
disclaimer would be like
maybe we could relapse you know oh yeah
that's fun a day and a relapse go back
to the good old days that's right well
hopefully none of you guys are uh gonna
relapse tonight if you do please do it
outside I'd hate to have a relapse
inside it's more of an outdoor activity
is it
um I don't know I've never done drugs
before me neither uh but we're gonna
have fun are you guys ready to watch
your first couple day tonight it's one
of you guys
foreign we're gonna pick a female and a
male we got
Julia coming up Terio
Julia and tario
stairs are right over here
[Applause]
stairs are right over there towards that
direction okay look at that he's a
creative guy
he made eye contact with me before he
did that
it's tario and Julia for one minute
starting now good group
you guys are dating each other look at
her oh okay okay okay she's trying to
[ __ ] me so um
how are you
here what made you come out tonight
um I
all my co-workers asked me okay yeah
yeah didn't know a lot about you
co-workers you talk about your daily
life at work okay okay I show up and I
open my laptop and then I shoot the [ __ ]
for some bit and then I have lunch and
then I go home okay what do you do
um it's
it's a Consulting intermediary
in less syllables please okay okay what
do you do you do please oh medical
laboratory scientist uh
yeah I was the one who put the tracker
in the Kobe vaccines okay okay so you
know everybody can follow you wherever
you're going this is a perfect first day
oh
yeah air tags um okay anyway but no uh
but now I'm taking them like a two-month
Hiatus off work okay and I should be
traveling and like doing cool [ __ ] but
like I just kind of sit in my apartment
and day trade and like play guitar all
day like yeah
yeah kind of like a loser right now but
like um and time
give it up for Ontario and Julia
[Applause]
you sit around at home and day trade all
day or a real life redditor in the flesh
outside of his normal habitat how did
you uh
do during the GameStop craze did you buy
any GameStop no no no no no I actually
made money you know so oh yeah yeah okay
you put it got enough money to track
your dates on dates
um I make enough money to get the extra
guac at Chipotle okay yeah yeah
and uh Julia how's your job as a
Consulting intermediary
um I quite enjoy it some days yeah so
when someone's about to get consulted
you're like hold on wait a minute let me
get in the way of this in between there
right right I convinced them too okay
yeah like you have a problem right right
you need help yeah and I make commission
off of that
indeed and this is like a whole bunch of
you guys right here A bunch of
Consulting intermediaries
wow are you hiring
you're like I doodle on the laptop and
then I go to lunch that's that's the
kind of job I want yeah yeah that's for
the most part so it's a okay you get
paid for that that's cool yeah
all right
I think they're all Instagram models
yeah I think that's just code word for
going to Ibiza and dancing on Yachts or
whatever yeah in an ideal world for sure
Terio how's your uh science going what
do you actually do besides working for
Bill Gates and depopulating the world
and it's like that's what I actually do
man I kind of fell into it I actually
answered an ad in the dark web
um and all of a sudden they gave me this
job and I'm a scientist bro dark web is
that what you call black Twitter
it is what black Twitter is
nice so that's cool you got you got a
cool science job any uh do you do any
science to impress women on dates
um yeah I can um
I don't know you ever uh
you ever really been into something
right you're like oh man this is so cool
yeah then the more you did it you just
kind of like got less interested that's
my like mutant ability right like okay
you're like a good first bike all right
like oh he's so cool in the beginning
and that's why he's like ah
I shouldn't I didn't have to eat that
much of it you know like yeah so what's
like an interesting science fact that
you tell people
um foreign
we all have a different smell about us
that attract other people to us
and what is uh what are you smelling
right now any pheromones in there
they got chicken wings
I'm gonna [ __ ] your chicken wings
go on a date and
impress your chicken wings with science
yeah Julia what uh what how why were you
a little hesitant to say you were here
with your co-workers you maybe you don't
want to tell everyone what you're doing
you're afraid of getting tracked right
right right that is a main concern also
um
I don't know okay thanks for adding that
at the end
um that's cool are you uh vaccinated are
you kind of worried about 5G and all
wait let me check my phone
no I figured the Thousand other things
I think okay that's good you're afraid
of a lot of different things not just
one specific thing
that's good any uh
any advice for this lovely couple Rachel
any any tips or tricks or anything you
noticed yeah are y'all gonna [ __ ] I mean
like
any advice on stage have sex what do you
how do you like ask her some questions I
guess you okay yeah I can ask you a
question how awkward do you feel right
now
uh scale of one to ten yeah
I'm like two really yeah you take Xanax
no
sure
she's a woman in Austin she's used to a
lot of awkward first dates with Nerds
present
yeah maybe not so many looking right at
her but
have you been dating in Austin I have I
have what's that's that experience been
like uh very
um is the word
fever dream
just happened
really and then you move on with your
life yeah yeah
a lot of guys coming on bird scooters
right leaving in a huff or or
arriving in a half oh okay they have a
lot of drama going on me no the the
dudes coming in the house they're like
you won't believe what my startup just
told me to do
um yeah I guess so I recently graduated
and the age-old question was what's your
what's your major and that's the one
where your eyes glaze over and you're
like [ __ ] I don't want to be here
anymore as soon as they drop that
question right and then the the new one
um like out of college I've noticed was
who did you vote for it is not provided
no but well what do you do maybe yeah
what do you do yeah yeah and how do you
answer that you don't always say
Consulting intermediary do you I do and
then it's a lot of questions yeah
explain it I'm like 32 so like my
questions are like how many kids you got
over your crazy exes and like you know
those kind of stuff like Julia how many
kids you got
zero that I know that you know yeah no
okay no I'm crazy
well luckily
tauren what's your name tario tario yeah
it's like Mario but with a t bro oh
that's my dad's name
uh no no
Brazilian
yeah
what is your dad a plumber a Brazilian
plumber
oh very smart family so smart
tario what do you think do you think
that uh
maybe uh you could tell her how many
kids that you have yeah how many do you
think I have
uh uh I don't want to say this on on in
front of people how many how many kids
do you think I take care of
I mean I think you can take care of at
least six Yeah by those earrings
[Music]
[Laughter]
no I got no kids man no marriages no
kids okay just been hanging out you're
fresh and ready to go you're unblemished
I want to like the Downs out of fresh
bro like my knees hurt oh okay that
stuff
yeah that's all that vaccine makes sense
yeah you got vaccinated yeah I get like
three day hangovers now yeah it was
terrible bro like I can't do anything
oh really so maybe you could just smoke
weed do you guys want to do that maybe
right now
do you got any yeah
black guy here if he has weed it's a
little racist yeah let me drive back bro
chill like
Julia what do you think about uh
the the whole uh kids situation would
you ever want kids
uh very very very very long time from
now perhaps okay you just want to pop
one out and then die
right in that order preferably yeah yeah
like someone else take care of this I'm
out of here
that's good that way you your jeans pass
on
yeah they're great ones
tario have you avoided having children
thus far from 30 years of your life
that's amazing well you know it takes a
lot of discipline hard work your pullout
game strong uh pull out don't worry you
never get in you know like you know it's
just
it just depends on like which way you
look at it if you look at time it's just
a circle you know so yeah okay I think
it's just so that you don't get it in a
lot that's surprising it's relative
relative yeah what's a lot does that
mean you [ __ ] your cousins or what does
that mean well I am from Mississippi man
oh [ __ ]
he's from Mississippi yeah yeah right
next to Alabama so like you know it's
the tradition down there yeah there you
go if you don't [ __ ] your cousin it's
considered rude you know when in Rome
yeah you think your cousin's ugly when
you want to Rome Mississippi yeah you do
what you gotta do you know what uh
what's like a Mississippi tradition that
you could take Julia to maybe the
Crawfish Boil diabetes diabetes how
excited we should get diabetes together
girl we can like share insulin
that's pretty much it welcome to the
South
um I guess this is the north of Brazil
but this is a South for us right where
are you from in the states I'm actually
from Houston oh neat what part The Burbs
I'm from Katie I'm from Kingwood so I'm
familiar yeah yeah yeah cool holy [ __ ]
you guys both just turned into white
women right now well I'm Mexican too but
oh yeah we don't yeah two she's
Brazilian she's not Mexican she's
Mexican Mexican too yeah oh okay my bad
I wasn't listening
have you ever been in a fight in a
physical fight
um oh my God I'm gonna say the most
cliche Austin [ __ ] ever right
too and so like yeah so you have or you
haven't yeah I mean I do it like for
sport like I go to jiu jitsu right yeah
it's fun man you know kind of enjoy it
after a while you know Julia what do you
think he does Brazilian Jiu Jitsu he's
familiar with your customs Jesus
yeah that's that's really cool I really
I don't know I could dance samba too I
think maybe oh would you like to show us
a little yeah
of course not of course I got boots on
it's really hard to sob in Boots you
know you need to have fast feet let's
just hear the music come on and hear you
sing a different tune okay yeah I'll do
it if you do it
dude wait
is there a difference
okay
Wow music please
whoa
[Music]
is this song of Music next what is this
the [ __ ] elevator music yeah
look at that that's a lot of steps
any minute now we're gonna get some
zombies
twirl foreign
why don't you do the uh bend over and
then put the rose in her mouth or
whatever
what culture is that from
oh the Spanish it's flamico oh right
totally different my bad yeah yeah it's
from upper Mexico yeah
I don't know I like to dance what are
you doing
Nick is the whitest sound guy ever and I
think he's just playing the music from
his people
we would like some fiery Latin music
please not your mother's [ __ ] yeah
the music she plays in her parlor
anyways thanks Nick uh
it's just getting worse
yeah
what is it
okay
it's a lot of
chair dancing now yeah
it's too real yeah yeah it's too real
okay let's just save that music and then
next time we want to you know spice it
up we can just start playing that watch
people dance
it'll add to the atmosphere so you ever
bust out a move at a club you ever do
that [ __ ] at a you know over here on
rain or something yeah yeah yeah I like
Latin dance a lot man you know Bachata
salsa Moringa and all that awesome and
uh Julia do you ever do you know some
dancing from tario's culture maybe a
twerk a two-step work a Spaniard Park
running around
yeah little Dougie
soldier boy
Junior High
yeah yeah hi because all those
references are really old though yeah
man um
yeah I'm 33. yeah we're old we are man
soldier boy was the [ __ ] you don't even
know I remember man I was there for it I
know I was trying to get Julia Julia
what's the what's music are you
listening to nowadays a lot of Bad Bunny
um or like
angsty teen
angsty team angry okay yeah never never
grew out of it you listen to a lot of
Katie Texas Music
group in the verbs hey guys
yeah that's awesome anyways uh tario
what do you what do you think about uh
taking Julia on a second date oh yeah I
think Julie on the second day what would
you do what would you take her Latin
dancing I'll just saying like we can go
and get like um
lighting food and go letting dancing and
then like you know get take a Latin walk
I don't know
what is that where your cat call woman
while you're on a date hey I don't know
depending on what language but yeah
that's awesome Julia what do you think
would you think that you want to go
Latin dancing anytime soon
um
um
sure
yeah
what uh what What place would you go to
any venues you have in mind that is a
lovely question he's the Planner yeah uh
this place right on 6th Street okay it's
like you know walk right around the
corner it's like a Latin place like
I think just I thought the street from
the Coyote Ugly I think I thought Julia
would have a little Mexican radar a Mech
star
and a good place started dancing in a
chewies it's broken
so how uh latinx all right Latina are
you Chris is not enough versus white
would you say you're like 90 white
um like genetically just like how much
of your is Katie Texas and how much of
you is Brasilia uh I would say half and
half yeah oh nice yeah what's the most
uh Brazilian thing that you can do can
you cook some uh
okay uh no that's Colombia
no one ever taught me how to cook
cocaine unfortunately oh yeah it's the
ancient tradition
[Laughter]
how are you feeling you think you could
uh maybe teach Julia how to cook cocaine
or
you know let's do a couple rap songs uh
I'm pretty sure the recipe is in there
somewhere and then like uh we'll cook it
up do you do cocaine is that a thing ah
what's the tense of that question
uh past perfect
I don't know it's open to interpretation
okay yeah talk to enough people in
Austin just people just blow the [ __ ] in
your face you know yeah it's everywhere
just go on 6th Street start snorting the
sidewalk yeah yeah ketamine or Coke are
either one works that's cool so yeah you
guys uh go out on a date together and uh
please let us know if uh you guys go on
a second date and please come back thank
you guys so much for coming out all
right we did it Julia
foreign
[Applause]
the first date of the night
and that's the standard everyone needs
to
try to get to that level well we got
Emma L coming up and Mike
wow
coming in from the center Mike Mike wall
Court
Wahoo he has bad handwriting he might be
a doctor
um
he got it what's up bro
Mike with Emma L going on a date for one
minute starting now
hi Emma how's it going good how are you
what brings you down to the creek in the
cave on Sunday night
um I honestly was just looking around
online and I found the show and I was
like that would be really funny
so I decided to come how about you right
on uh I'm a repeat offender I uh
repeatedly tried to get dates on this
show so
well I think uh as this day progresses
you'll find out
okay okay so uh what do you do when
you're not trying to get dates on the
show I I live in Hawaii I
surf I ride bikes I try to tell jokes
fair enough so Hawaii and Austin where's
the
connect there Hawaiian Airlines flies
here directly and I have many many miles
from work for Hawaiians
that's fair so how much of the year do
you spend in Hawaii
uh 99.9 I'd say and time give it up for
Mike and Emma L
Mike putting in a cliffhanger in the
middle of his date yep wait around and
find out why I don't get dates yeah yeah
what a Twist let's do that background
check maybe it'll uh oh yeah that's why
he lives in Hawaii
he's he's gonna commit a crime here and
then escape on a Hawaiian Airlines
flight yeah
Emma so uh how long have you been in
Austin
I've been in Austin for about three and
a half to four years wow you're pretty
much a native at this point
longer than 99 of the people here uh
that's cool so you would like just
looking around on the internet you found
this you're like oh like Tinder in real
life
pretty much yeah
so uh yeah Mike what did you uh what did
you think about the date did you think
that maybe you could have just tried to
you know get laid a little harder
yeah I could definitely try harder than
that that was that was terrible
I love a relationship that starts out
with an apology yeah that's gonna it's
gonna last a long time
are you on the app so you mentioned
Tinder
yeah actually tinder's the only
one I tried that new on a true social
it's just a bunch of men on there
I haven't even heard of that one what's
wrong with men
well they're all angry and white on that
one so that means they're more of a
press the sex is hotter it's she yeah
might have to get some extra lube yeah
just stick a finger in there it'll blow
their mind
wow talking about fingering Trump
supporters please don't come after me
this is being streamed live on the
internet I just let you know anyways
so Mike what uh what do you think do you
think that uh maybe Emma would like to
come to Hawaii what would you where
would you go with her in Hawaii where
would you show her
oh um you know the it's the birthplace
of Surfing it's a wonderful place to try
and learn how to surf if you've ever
been there at Waikiki has the most
amazing Gentle Way that comes in
um and we go there maybe do some surfing
I'd uh I'm sure you're quite familiar
with the homeless and Austin so I'd show
you the homeless in Wiki key a little
homeless tour yeah sexy some cocaine
hopefully
Emma so uh
would you uh would you like to go
surfing I know you're good at surfing
the web yeah
I've been surfing one time in
[Music]
well you did it once and you're like I'm
never doing this again it was so much
fun
never gonna do it until some guy takes
me to Hawaii
and shows you some homeless people
yeah
does the homeless people naturally lead
to surfing like oh let's just wash off
in the ocean
there there are some homeless Surfers
there's this one place that's kind of
strictly for body surfing that's where
you just use you swim into the wave and
for the homeless love that there's some
dudes that live in the park that's like
yeah they they pretty much that's how
they shower yeah nuts you know salt
water vents it's nice exfoliating
leaves you a sticky hair Rachel what did
you what do you think about this couple
you think that uh maybe Emma will go to
Hawaii or no I don't
that was a very quick answer
yeah
what do you do for
um I'm a medical assistant I may all
right and sir
I am a Forester right
what's that mean
it's it's a good question that uh
it used to mean you know you grow trees
for Pulp and Paper production or
whatever that's what I like learned in
school
but most of the work that I've done has
been endangered species management
habitat restoration work and now I
manage the Wildland fire program
well that's an awesome thing you should
be proud of that
maybe tell girls you should wait till we
get further in the date to find out how
awesome I am
instead of why you don't have dates yeah
yeah well I was nervous so yeah you
could take Emma out to watch the spotted
horned owl or whatever
the horned
the horny horny Hill
like you know you think that thing's
horny
anyways
[Laughter]
what uh what would you do what what
could you show Emma you know like in
nature or something well uh just so
happens that Mauna Loa started erupting
last week and so that is definitely a
natural phenomenon that was spouting
Fountains of fire oh does that sound
interesting is uh impending doom yeah
is Vesuvius I actually uh lived near an
active
wolf so I'm pretty used to that oh
where's where's that
wow two Islanders meeting up what are
the chances yeah and then you we're like
I'm not gonna go surfing here I'm gonna
wait till I'm in Malibu
well the Caribbean is very flat so
there's not a lot of Surfing and on the
Atlantic side the island I lived on is
all Rocky beaches so it wasn't
of course we all know this about Island
life is that is that Epstein's island or
is that
okay now we know why he doesn't have
dates
wait till the third day for an Epstein
reference
so Emma do you think Epstein killed
himself
no the cops are coming for you
you were answered incorrectly
yep Mike obviously agrees with you let's
not get too far into it with Mike
he might start busting out his keyboard
and start redditing
Mike what's the craziest conspiracy
theory that you believe in
um
the one the craziest that I believe in
um don't think too hard it's should be
right at the tip of your tongue
uh
911 was an inside job I don't know oh
that's some old school [ __ ] man yeah I'm
pretty old so nice
Emma do you remember 911 yeah
I was one
you're one one or two
okay I'll never forget
he'll carry the trauma with us every
American couple needs one person to
remember 911.
that's what Epstein told his victims
what do you think Rachel do you remember
911 oh yeah what were you doing uh
sleeping I was in college oh that's a
good way to celebrate skipping school
watching actually now I was watching
Lord of the Rings and then yeah
yo have you checked out this bootleg
copy of Lord of the Rings
that's crazy people were crying and I
was like oh
and got it got it off of LimeWire oh the
old plane in the building again yeah
what a crazy time that was the 2000s
yeah
yeah
I was in Middle School
yeah just going to school just
respecting the towers
be like I'm gonna Someday I'm gonna tell
a young woman I shouldn't be dating
about this
I'm gonna wish I didn't remember this so
I would not get arrested
um that's cool Emma what's the what's
the first national disaster that you
remember
and are you American what the hell were
you doing in the Caribbean
oh [ __ ] I'm sorry I know you've never
lived there was just born there
um
but my parents moved down to the
Caribbean when I was 10 so I grew up
there and I honestly don't really
remember any national
what what island did you live on
Dominica Dominica
you know Dominica Island what the [ __ ]
God damn this guy travels
travels around it doesn't do cocaine
uh that's cool so uh yeah you don't
remember any national disasters uh Mike
if you had to explain 911 in one
sentence
how would you do it
911 was an inside job
okay now you're all caught up Emma
that's it
it's for the spark notes
um yeah any uh where where do you think
you would take Emma if you were to go on
a date in Austin
in Austin uh I don't know Austin
particularly well maybe a museum there's
a lot of museums around here it seems
like so they're fun yeah you can take
notes together yeah Emma what's like a
cool little niche place in Austin that
you would like to take
updates to
that's a great question I
haven't really honestly explored Austin
that
in them because I've been here for a
while but I'm
um but I do like to go to the Black Star
Co-op when I have free time the co-op
the co-op they're pretty good awesome
coffee or beer they're a brewery oh okay
nice
yeah that's a cool Austin spot
you could go there Mike
I'm down okay tell her yeah maybe Emma
will go with you oh would you
would you would you like to go with
black sour coffee with me
um
I think you might be a little old for me
honestly no offense
Mike is your mustache dyed the same
color as your eyebrow
yeah it's it's just my uh my my beard
that's white it just go like this
get me bro
Grecian formula a little Grecian formula
on top there
that's cool Emma
um well that's sad Emma what uh
what are you what are you looking for in
a human male
someone who's close to my age oh okay we
got that please get it we don't want
Mike to kill himself yeah
we need him to go back to Hawaii to save
the spotted owl I I am at that age where
some women like to call you Daddy in bed
so okay that's not helping at all
it made it worse
what's the oldest guy that you've dated
Emma
I think like
33. damn
how old are you
23. yeah
yeah okay well Mike I think you're still
in the game you still got a chance how
old are you Mike I'm 47. oh
and he's out
so more like Grandpa bed
that's right I'm like a fine wine yeah
people aged differently in Hawaii he
doesn't even remember the 2008 stock
market crash
uh Emma so what's uh what do you do in
Austin what what keeps you so busy that
you can't even Explore anywhere
just got into medical school oh wow
congratulations congratulations
and besides that I work as a medical
assistant
um I do a lot of tutoring that'll be
great because when Mike is in Hospice in
five years
needs that new hip and a couple
you're gonna be his nurse nurse
girlfriend
doctor doctor oh [ __ ] doctor what what
do you think your specialty will be
breaking hearts yes
exactly cardio pulmonary
whatever I don't know definitely I just
look like a doctor I'm not actually a
doctor
my fiance is actually pre-med there we
go oh yeah
when the date's not going well that's
right that out stay out it's the golden
parachute we we talked about it last
week I think
what's the weather alert
yes for all the uh people that were here
last week this is a running gag is how
Mike is in a relationship but yet going
on dates with 23 year olds
a trade out huh
I do drive a white van
the fiance is uh in danger we gotta go
help her
Gabby potatoes boyfriend right here
so Emma anything that you'd like to say
to Mike before you guys never see each
other again ever again
no
maybe some medical advice yeah ask Tom
to take some Metamucil okay vitamins
it's good advice
take your vitamins Mike anything you'd
like to say to Emma
911 was an inside job give it up for
Mike and Emma L
this is going out on YouTube
[Music]
let's get another couple up here we got
we got coal
here we go Cole with a big O Bart
she did not expect to be called she's
going on a date with Bart she's
exchanging places with Emma give it up
for a Bart
and Cole
[Applause]
one minute of dating starting now
um hi hi
what do you do for fun
um fun things of any kind
okay
live I like doing things that are uh
something different than I did the last
time
okay that I did that was fun
okay just try a new drug every week like
yeah yeah okay how about you
um I do pole dancing
that sounds fun I'm not a sherpa before
y'all get too excited I know
so strictly for uh Health purposes
exercise and I look hot
nice yep
that's awesome yeah but it's a lot
funner than what I do for fun yeah
funner is not a word uh what do you do
for a living
uh I'm an optical engineer
what's that
I do
hearing on optical things okay and time
give it up for the super vague Bart
and coal
wow your name is really coal
okay I was gonna say you look like you
look like someone who would protest
against
her name is literally c-o-a-l what uh
what made you choose that name my name
is Nicole but I'm non-binary so I'd go
back home okay it's a gender identity
what's that someone's like not from
Austin yeah yeah what's happening
she just came in from Katy Texas
oh my God I thought there were two
genders
uh but yes thank you for coming please
uh get vaccinated
um
so cold so uh uh you just took the ni
out and now you're just cold as that
ever led to any confusion any hilarious
instances
also my middle name
like well Nicole's my name they're like
you're first I'm like no so it's just a
whole thing and I like [ __ ] with
people with it nice yeah wow so your
middle name is Nicole and it's why did
you go by coal instead of c-o-l-e which
is because c o l e is boring okay
who doesn't love some good coal it is
what powers this show after all
uh
Bart
what uh why do you look like one of the
robbers from Home Alone yeah
probably because I'm from the Northwest
oh nice you're uh your rugged
Outdoorsman
what uh what have you any have you
robbed any cool houses recently
tons of cool houses what uh what do you
look for in uh in a robbery
cool
I'll be sure how to answer that oh my
gosh you're such a nice sweet man
are you sure you're not non-binary as
well yeah
you have the gentleness of a woman and
the beard of a man
offense to that
which part I don't even know what I said
I apologize to the community
so which came first the hair color or
the name change
name change
that's easy you just get it over with
and you're like now time for the look
yeah
yeah got a match
how's the uh Austin scene been treating
you how's it in Austin
I hate it oh okay well thank you for
coming anyways no guy
no guys I have no idea what you're
talking about you're wrong
Bart said he's into fun things
conversationalist he does one thing and
then it goes to the next fun thing yeah
that's my fun thing definition
Bart is having a fun time he's just all
sorts of fun look at him
he's having a blast right now
this is his this is his o face yeah
that's what he looks like when he's
coming uh Cole you do pole dancing how
how did you fall into that line of a
hobby
um I needed to do something for exercise
and why go to the normal gym when you
can strap eight inch heels to your feet
and swirl around in the air nice you're
like let me exercise on something that's
shaped like me
yeah yeah
coal on the pole coal on the pole I do
have an Instagram account Cole does pull
that's not a that's not a porn site
where you blow polish dudes is it no not
yet not yet she said any polish guys in
here
everyone yeah
uh so uh Bart
yes how are you feeling you're making me
nervous
I don't know this is really
uncomfortable I don't know why you say
that
Bart have you ever uh talked to a woman
ever I have
and uh when was the last time that you
went on a date with one
about a month ago how'd that go
it was fine it was good nice
I don't want to know
Bart is uh efficient answer of questions
so uh what ended up happening why didn't
you go out for a second date
uh we went on a second date
and
then
then
I
didn't call her back whoa playing hard
to get breaking hearts they were like
this girl is not as quiet as I am
yeah I'm much quieter
what uh so what do you look for in a
date
I like people that are
open to experience and
instinctively kind to
animals and old people you're looking
for a Snow White
that doesn't exist
how often do animals interact with you
on dates yeah
how do you find out if they're
instinctively
it happens you know dogs walk by and
stuff
yeah
it's like oh you didn't slap the [ __ ]
out of this dog that walked by exactly
yeah it's a bit of a red flag
Cole uh how are you with animals I
actually have five pets I have three
cats and two dogs
okay is that is that kind enough or is
that a little too kind to animals
fine
you made the cut Cole a little more
vague if you could
hahaha
foreign
so uh how did you uh fall into five
animals how did that happen
what we thought was his same breed but
she's a Chihuahua mix and then we got
another dog because the old dog died and
he's deaf and then we got a disabled cat
who's a [ __ ] and then we got she can say
that look at her my dad is British it's
fine but
um all of our dads are British okay and
then
um and then my mom found two uh cats on
a Facebook Marketplace in Waco so she
drove and got them oh my God
what a hero saving cats from Waco she
should have taken a couple people with
her too yeah for sure true
so that's awesome you guys just have a
big Noah's Ark over there lesbian Noah's
Ark yeah it's hot the fagified Noah's
Ark Bart what do you think about all
this [ __ ]
that's a lot of a lot of cats yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
I found a lane I'm going with the veg
you found a what I found a lane for
myself here I think he's self-aware yeah
that's cool you uh you're from the
Northwest so you you don't uh
work with pets that aren't useful or
tasty
do you uh do you have any pets yourself
I do not
red flag
did you say red flag
[Laughter]
he's taking it in he's processed it
why don't you have any pets dude
[Music]
I move a lot and so
I don't know when you uh when you gotta
Escape town after you committed it just
hasn't been the right time I would love
to have a dog
or a cat
the responsible man doesn't want to take
on responsibilities he can't fulfill
can't take him on the burglaries with
you yeah they make good Watch Dogs you
know
plant went outside
what do you think about bart he's a
little weird
slightly
he just seems nervous
yeah yeah
and Bart what what do you like in high
school what were you a stoner or
even special ed
nice
did you graduate
uh you didn't graduate high school
oh
uh I actually dropped out of ninth grade
hell yeah what a rebel
Cole hates institutions so she's on
board
and what uh what did you do you just
went out in the mountains just started
Living with Bigfoot
kind of
what'd you do really
what did you do after ninth grade
uh
I kind of
traveled a bit
in sort of an irresponsible teenager
kind of way
you're like I'm gonna make my life as
difficult for a dog as possible yeah
could have stayed in ninth grade and had
a dog dude
always go back
Cole what's your uh highest level of
Education
um I'm currently an esthetician
oh so zero education I graduate
you what I drive
oh wow what a scholar and yeah
what do you think about this uh educated
woman in front of you or uh very
educated
what's something that you could maybe
teach Bart since he didn't go through
high school at all
probably nothing because I was
homeschooled so I cheated on everything
how do you cheat when you're in
your teacher no if it's the computer
program teaching you you just Google the
[ __ ] you don't have parents
they don't love me enough to pay
attention yeah look at her look at
She's Gotta rebel against something
she definitely didn't grow up in Katy
Texas
[Music]
that's cool so uh you cheated a lot
was it a Christian homeschooling thing
oh nice that's how you get your daughter
to have purple hair
yeah so what uh what would you teach uh
Bart about Jesus
well he's an [ __ ] whoa
I am Bart what's your religious uh
beliefs
uh pretty agnostic
there you have something in common kind
of
you have a lot in common actually
[Laughter]
Bart do you have any tattoos
I do not
what a surprise yeah
you didn't even get one in ninth grade
you were like [ __ ] school I'm out of
here
if only you treated your body with the
same carelessness you did your education
yeah yeah
so you what did you do after uh ninth
grade what do you do for a living now
well uh I'm an optical engineer how did
you get that without a high school
diploma well
um
I just decided to
try to do it I went back to school for
four years got
a degree in engineering and then
good for you then I did well with that
there's no excuses especially I work
with people with phds
nice with the nerdiest of nerds that's
why you're so quiet
dealing with Nerds all day they respect
quiet
um that's cool yeah you you just went
back to school did the college thing for
four years and now you're staring into
microscopes and telescopes and
yeah
cool yeah
I'm glad you know what Optical means
thanks man
I went to school too I actually
graduated from high school
of a nerd yeah in college
uh Cole what uh what how how do you
think you could use a guy with this
expertise maybe he could take you you
know stargazing yeah maybe you could
look at your Poll for cracks
I'm good
what do you do for a living
I currently work at the front desk of a
swim school a swim school a swim school
wow that's not a real school it's
so you're studying to be an esthetician
yes so you like uh working with Esther's
or
do you know what esthetician means I
think it's like beauty stuff right
stuff yeah
what do you what do you think about uh
estheticians as a career you think
that's a good Avenue for her to go down
or
yeah see
that's what she wants to be awesome I
don't give a [ __ ] what people do
just don't be lazy
with you you what I want to go on date
with you
thanks you're welcome great I gotta [ __ ]
Bart now
Bart I'll take coal Bart and I are gonna
play chess together you guys or you just
play the silent game
there's a poll back there you guys can
rub on or whatever
the lucky
um
come on BART give us one thing fun that
you did
I play music there you go now we're
getting somewhere what does that mean
what do you I mean it means I've uh it
means I play musical instruments yeah
yeah I get that you started off with
that as a descendants sort of what
musical instrument do you like playing
the most
um
I played drums for a long time I'm
learning piano now cool so I play with
like a community jazz band all right now
we're getting somewhere nice maybe you
could accompany uh you know Cole as he
dances with your community jazz band
with the pool sexiest
pull music
anyways that's cool so you you do a
piano now and drums
you wanna yeah you wanna lay down a sick
beat
do we have a piano
not really sure how to just do it
okay never mind this is making me
uncomfortable
in the same boat you can can you
I'm a terrible singer ah
sing us a tune
no that was good
that's what Cole is going to be saying
later to you tonight
just kidding you're still in the game
Cole what do you look for in a date
besides the absence of a penis
[Music]
I mean she was really into Rachel
I don't know
um I do like people with tattoos because
I have I have seven tattoos it's kind of
a problem but uh
outgoing probably
what is it that you like about tattoos
you just want to see how people decorate
themselves yeah that too
we can get a couple hennas on Brett Bart
if you want
I'm gonna tat it up and ready I'm good
oh
the alcohol it's a tattoo place oh okay
what tattoos do you have what do they
mean to you
um most of them don't mean anything and
it's I have one for pets that died on my
wrist I have one on my arm that's a
fairy to remind me to love myself and
then I have angel numbers on my ribs
angel numbers yeah I'm a spiritual [ __ ]
no way shocker
that's cool she's cool angel numbers
Bart
what do you think about angel numbers
I don't know I didn't learn anything
about angel numbers in physics
you're too busy studying real science
touche
that's cool what kind of numbers would
you get tattooed on you
that's a good question
I'd probably get the logistic function
oh
logistic function what does that look
like it's like an S curve so
it's like if you have a population that
never mind oh my God I tell nobody's
gonna listen to whatever you're making
people leave
people love that [ __ ]
that's really an honest answer from a
guy that dropped out of high school
this guy knows what I'm talking about
ass and totes
he's got so much ass in the Northwest
he's got to carry them around in a tote
bag
ass in tote
anyways uh Cole what uh what do you have
to say to uh Bart right now any any
messages of
hope you seem nice
oh thank you yeah yeah yes Nice Guys
Finish First yeah
borrow any uh any words of uh wisdom for
a coal maybe about 9 11.
on this one actually
Bigfoot for real what Bigfoot is there
one or is it a species there is a
correct answer
uh I think it's a species okay good nice
you guys are interesting
it's like young Sheldon meets Wednesday
that's right
give it up for young Sheldon and
Wednesday I forget their names Bart and
Cole
what a wonderful date it was pretty good
Styles make dates and those are two very
different types of human beings
can't even believe they're the same
species
we got a human female named sway sway
coming up going on a date or touring
Luke torik
here he comes the Luke all right
sway
is that your rap name yes
sway is not coming oh here she is sway
from the bathroom
give it up for a sway and Luke
Luke is ready for a marathon
going on a date for one minute starting
now
what'd you say names Again Luke okay
um last question what do you do for fun
oh
um I'm big in like pick up Sports play a
lot of soccer
um I
just do a lot of like listening to music
writing what kind of music
um I'm I'm with whoever that was before
who left like angsty stuff I'm still
stuck in like that one era of like
Linkin Park and Blink 182 and stuff and
I listen to a lot of like independent
singer-songwriter types okay how about
you you into that kind of music or
something I kind of listen to everything
I love country rap
Christian like anything I just hate Rock
ouch
like
like emo stuff like I'm sorry I just
don't I can't do the screaming oh no
yeah okay I can't do screamo either it's
like totally different from what I'm
into so like if you had if you had like
one artist you listen to just off like
Parker McComb
is that country yep okay I'd pretend to
like know but I you know I told myself
I'd be honest here yeah no that's great
I appreciate the honesty and time give
it up for a sway and Luke
[Applause]
Luke honestly doesn't know much about
your culture sway
all right he's about to
learn you're a [ __ ] young country
music fan that's very rare I do like it
well one of my friends
um plays in a band so I just support him
and it's country so I love it I've come
to love it nice yeah it's not bad as
long as you get past the racism
uh has anyone ever called you Molly
Parton
because you love country and you look
like you do Molly I mean we are
we we are in Texas so yee-haw
indeed he's in Texas that's for sure
Luke what's the most Yeehaw thing that
you've done in Texas so far
oh I've only been here like two days so
where are you from I'm from Phoenix all
right so I'm here for work holy [ __ ]
that's the Alabama of this of the West
is it I I don't have any family out
there so I haven't dabbled where where
are you from
you haven't dabbled in Phoenix out in
the Alabama thing oh okay I'm from
Tennessee oh I got it so nice so you're
from the south yep you just don't Vibe
with country music
it's not that I don't Vibe with it it's
just it's not your favorite yeah you
know like it's like on the playlist on
shuffle but sometimes when it comes on
I'll skip it yeah they're concerning
each other's sentences already I know
this is a beautiful eye but it expect
you guys to get along
we know each other yeah oh really yeah
how
we will
you're great yeah at school but we work
together too
sounds like a lie yeah sounds like
you're making it up on the fly yeah ask
us questions yeah
what where do you work I work for
software advice
where do you work
software advice I'm not gonna play that
game
why haven't you guys [ __ ] before then
because I'm a virgin whoa so wow you do
like country music yeah
but you moved here two days ago uh well
so we work at it's a cyber security
home International so oh interesting
okay is country music Big in the cyber
security Community it depends who you
are that's awesome you put on a straw
hat and you hack away
okay yeah okay
Luke looks more like a cyber security
this is what I imagine some redditor
is it
is it because I'm white and bald there's
do you have something else come on the
beard doesn't help yeah well the problem
is if you go bald like you gotta have
like something interesting about your
face and I couldn't I'm not like I
couldn't do tattoos so I just
you know it just happens you just put an
accent on it put a little rug on your
face yeah exactly that's wonderful I
think it's going great for you you're a
very beautiful man thank you appreciate
it Luke what's the uh what's the uh most
uh controversial subreddit that you're a
part of right now
um I I can't say that I'm a part of any
subreddits I'm sorry oh you don't uh
you're not individual to any you know I
just browse all the you're an atheist
weird ones yeah of course sway uh why is
your name Sway and can you rap for us a
little bit okay first of all I cannot
rap so
it just stuck
because you're a drunk and you were
swaying around
I'm going to use that I don't know this
random kid just gave it to me he's like
yours and you just stuck with it yeah I
just stuck with it it's kind of cool
it's easy four letters what's your real
name Paley Haley whoa sound like a plant
I've never had a plant like that but
okay Haley
okay
uh well it describes the kind of music
you like
pale music
uh
hey I did give all a most genres besides
Rock so I wouldn't say that's as pale
but okay yeah okay good for you uh Luke
what uh what do you like to do for fun
soccer
yeah so I mean keep up she did ask me
this like 30 seconds ago but I'm
actually not here I'm thinking about
something else he loves so I'm curious
pretty athletic
that's awesome
do you do any sports sway or do you just
get into fights and trailer parks
[Music]
the wall but track and chair were my
main
nice I heard there's a lot of injuries
in cheer are you ever did you ever get
injured
um I mean if you suck you get injured
like know your [ __ ] and execute it and
you'll be fine can you show us something
anything
um four years ago I could do a standing
back flip and some fools and stuff but
now I'm retired so I would be one of the
injured ones for sure
that's good know your limits
uh so what kind of cheer was it was it
the kind where that you would stand on
some dude's hand or like yeah
girl I was on a co-ed team I cheered for
a team called Cheer Athletics so we're
at division five so I mean division six
depending on what you cheer but yeah you
can do one man's nice yeah I've seen the
Netflix show I know all about it yeah
cheer yeah those are like half my
friends on that show I've seen the
trailer
I don't know if you like it but it's
entertaining if you're bored yeah what
is what is it that uh you like about
cheer cultures
um the community the
for each other it teaches you discipline
there's a bunch of stuff that you're
teaches you
yeah much like country music
I mean depending but yeah I love country
music I mean it's beer trucks and
[ __ ] that's all they rap about but
I'm here for it hell yeah some jeans
that fit just right
there you go oh look at that we got
Alabama over there
Alaska holy [ __ ] that's the opposite of
the South
you guys were killing each other during
the Civil War
and now look at you getting along
under racism
uh Luke what is your favorite uh thing
uh what do you look for in uh your
favorite thing in a date
I mean I think like
yeah definitely look for someone who's
talkative willing to talk about
themselves I'm like a big question asker
so I like to ask the questions then try
to yeah I don't know if we'd get along
well then or if that's like the wrong
thing to have in common but uh can be
good and bad
yeah and then I'd say like
someone who's willing to
take some risks I like to go on like
random
dates for things I haven't tried like
you know just go do something
spontaneous yeah like do some like
I went on a pottery date once where I'd
never made anything and neither cheat
and it was just fun like we just both
screwed up making a pot really bad
it was cool rock climbing never had
tried that before so yeah someone
willing to do something spontaneous and
interesting like going on a date with a
co-worker on stage yeah yeah well I mean
to be fair I don't think we thought that
we'd get drawn together yeah but fate
had other plans right
[ __ ] your jobs quit your jobs and go
move to the country and start making
Country Music Man
do you play any instruments
the drums my brother knows
how you can sway easier and when I'm mad
I can just hit it and it sounds kind of
good
yeah that's uh
that's how drums work
um so yeah that's cool you uh you you do
any musical stuff Luke
um not officially I was in like
abandoned high school which I think most
kids who listen to Emo music were
um but we weren't really any good we
just like played in a school Thing Once
and
you know recorded things that never saw
the light of day so
that's awesome you guys are such
different types of white people but uh
Bring It On versus Tenacious D
Iron Maiden
what uh what do you guys think that you
guys will get along in high school like
you'd be in the cheer section obviously
like the cool kids and then you'd be
brooding in the corner
with your razors yeah
I mean I had hair in high school so I
was like I had a chance I was like
decently cool yes it didn't fall out
until College
big thing for you yeah
well luckily you have a big strong body
and a beautiful ass
are you interested
I mean I was in the city I thought you'd
never ask but when in Austin you know
yeah Welcome to Austin no that's not a
mandatory butt [ __ ]
you ain't in Phoenix anymore
sway what do you think about uh Luke as
a as a co-worker
well he's hard working he does what he
needs to do
he's uh would you rely on him to support
you if he was on a cheer formation
together yeah
yeah whoa he just got she just called
you a side [ __ ]
bass yes I mean I'm involved there right
cheers oh that's sweet he's uh he's
ready to get friend zoned he's excited
about it yep
yep uh that's cool side base and what
what is your role what is that called
whatever you do it was a flyer and then
Senior Year I didn't want to be in the
air anymore so I chose to be a main base
and then flip the girls but my flyer was
like 10 pounds so I can't really give
myself a credit balance where you fly
like a chihuahua literally an abortion
it was a nice one she was the smallest
flyer and I was like I'll take her less
work for me so you were flipping [ __ ]
in the air yeah that's crazy how tall
are you five five oh my God that's
dangerous and what what would you make
him be the side [ __ ] when you're the
main bit it may have him because the man
is the shorter one oh of course
and he's not tall enough to be a back so
okay I don't know anything about
anything you like country music cheer
I'm full of fun facts I
what's the fun fact that uh you don't
think Luke knows about
were you in anything that we'd know yeah
I did CSI Las Vegas Days of Our Lives
Major Crimes I did Modern Family that
was the last thing I shot and then I
decided to be a normal kid and I moved
back here and I got my education good
for you thank you
[Applause]
child actress that isn't on drugs and
that's one of the reasons why is why I
quit one of my good friends Dylan
Minnette he
he wasn't anything and now he's in
everything and
yeah they they kind of come down some
wrong paths it's an industry that's kind
of [ __ ] up
um so well it sounds like it's working
out for him he's in everything he's in
everything now no he's working out he
just kind of lost his grounding he's not
the same person like I knew he was which
is he's much richer
he's happy
it's cool you're uh you're you're a
celebrity no okay
she didn't recognize me I'm not
12. what were you on CS
so in the scene my dad was gonna murder
my mom and then kill like me and then I
got away it was it was dumb it's all
fake so yeah I know it's fake
I was like this is wow what a traumatic
childhood you had oh it's it's a CSI
television yeah I had a cry on scene it
was a put myself through a lot as a
young kid
Luke what do you think about that do you
think that you could ever do that
will cry on Commander be having to be on
CSI because I've got angsty like locked
down yeah you have a lot of emotions I'm
sure oh yeah absolutely I feel a lot
I've been walking down the street and
just no one bothers me because I have
headphones and I think I just look
angry yeah you look like a bald angry
wife exactly I could blow up anytime you
know you look like the look like being a
bad guy in CSI yeah the bad guy I fun
fact I was in that episode
was he yeah it's just a fact oh my God
you guys are a bunch of beautiful Liars
yeah we don't know each other it's fine
that's true yeah I've never seen her
before in my life because they're a
wonderful actresses and actors actors
yeah yeah with your Hollywood magic
coming in here tricking us
away from gross who loves that
some people do not for me
what what do you like about Texas
I mean I've been here my whole life so I
have family everywhere that's one thing
I love
um I mean I mean Austin's a little
different but I mean
yeah in a good way right
yeah help it's different yeah you moved
to the most California part of Texas
well I'm
well I'm about 30 minute drive's not bad
so when I want to come here I do when I
don't I stay home nice
uh Luke what what do you what would you
say to uh sway to maybe convince her to
come down to Austin where the Liberals
are I'm here right now what do you mean
convince me I'm here right now well come
to come back again Luke has something to
say yeah
speak
I mean I just showed up for like the
barbecue and because my work made me so
I I got nothing I'm brand new here you
got to give me like a couple more days
to figure it out okay it's got good
comedy you know yeah great comment here
big fan of Bart he was smart Bart's here
that says that's his appeal as other men
yeah he's really
I'm here you can watch Luke and I make
love to each other
it could be the side base
as we suck and [ __ ]
I think we got her Luke I think she's
definitely coming back I'll be back
tomorrow
well give it up for the wonderful sway
and Luke
thank you for being on the show we got
time for one more couple
let's get another couple up here
got a lot of men
we got Julia n is that
is that you or is that another Julia
we got a table of julias over there
Jerry they travel in flocks
Jerry
human male Jerry coming up
[Applause]
Julia n
a going on a date with Jerry
a Consulting intermediary
what's up Jerry
the wonderfully wonderful smile of Jerry
going on a date for one minute starting
now okay
yeah how y'all doing how y'all doing hey
it's not ready uh great thank you good
yeah okay sorry just gonna take this all
in I did have an edible earlier so we're
just gonna see where this goes okay
what'd you do this weekend uh
thanks for asking I uh I went to a baby
shower yesterday uh for a good friend of
mine uh I'm in a little volleyball group
we played beach volleyball and you know
the other Julia
maybe there is a Julia that plays
volleyball yeah oh okay well anyway
sorry yeah it was at a baby shower it
was a volleyball baby shower okay
and we played some games and uh Mike you
know the diaper games and the bottle
games and you know you're drinking
liquor and stuff anyway what did you do
um I have a friend visiting in town so
showed her around Austin okay so are you
a native then to the area I was born
here and then I made like a real name
from San Antonio and now I live here
again oh okay I'm from Corpus so also
local but and fun fact not to man
explain but uh 512 we used to share that
area code
yeah Corpus yeah
and time give it up for uh
Billy Mays
and Julia n
wow some fun number facts that always
gets the girls going
did you know that Julia and I did not
maybe that could be your angel number
get a tattooed
five one two
did the edible just kick man yeah no I
should talk into the mic that's now
that's weird uh so just I'm like
Whispering over here I'm sorry you're
just whispering to yourself yeah no he
was talking about oh yeah I'm back
talking I just sorry Jerry is wrong of
me and I'm I'm in I'm in and I'm here
and I'm I'm present now here he is he's
got to breathe it in sometimes sorry
he's not [ __ ] it up wow you're doing
a great job Jerry we are all impressed
by
your uh you look like the Brawny paper
towel guy I I don't know it just came
you've moved to Austin and it just kind
of happens you know you just get a
flannel yeah Direction your beard starts
growing out of nowhere yeah well and I'm
a naturally very hairy guy so this is
just the easy way what's the hairiest
part of you oh my gosh it doesn't stop
it's kind of just you know ah
I'm half Scottish half Spanish so you
know I just I'm a hairy guy oh yeah a
half Scottish this is like I did the No
Shave November and it's already come all
the way back because it's nuts
um
that's cool very hairy guy it's making
me jealous over here I'm an Asian dude
man doesn't grow in like that for us hey
it's a good look man we all have our own
looks thank you Jerry very inclusive
message
What a Beautiful Soul
Julia what do you think about this
character he's fun yeah thank you looks
like a construction worker I think Julie
is fun too I would just over talk a
little bit I like to listen no I do too
I promise I do too whatever
yeah we're waiting for the evidence of
that but uh well take your word for it
Jerry Julia what is something that you
picked up in all your listening that
you've done so far any any quirks that
you notice about Jerry that he might not
know about
512 same area code is Austin and Corpus
Christi that's right
okay that's something he told you
um
that's cool so uh yeah how did you know
that did you uh you know you know a lot
about area I'm very old so you know I
grew up with that that was my phone
number and it was just this weird
annexation it was like we're 361 now and
that was just you know it really hit you
hard that area code yeah so I moved to
Houston and now I'm 281 so yeah okay
rappers and construction workers have a
Fascination for the area code that
they're in
um he lives in Houston you're from
Houston what do you think about the area
code there I don't give a [ __ ] man
I was from Clear Lake oh I was there for
like nine years cool that's good to know
tell her I was in Cleveland for like
nine years ago where were you before
before Oh no you're from Austin uh Clear
Lake on the Southeast side of Houston
but um yeah you know you don't meet a
lot of uh austinians austinites uh
that's my fun fact yeah so it's that's
that's really cool awesome you're a
native austinian yeah wow what did you
uh well I yeah I grew up in San Antonio
but I was born here right right
so uh did you know that five one two you
know how lucky you are to have that area
code
very lucky although it's not my area
code
San Antonio
so Julia n where would you uh take the
Brawny paper towel guy on a date in uh
in San Antonio
Maybe we
they're Sushi you like sushi love it
yeah I would I would definitely I Love
Sushi Seafood I bet that sounds good
yeah yeah what's your favorite kind of
sushi
um
I like salmon sashimi yeah those are my
salmon and tuna yeah yeah what's your
favorite role
I feel like it depends on the place they
all have their own
their own types do you like the spice
yes yeah yeah I can do a little bit of
spice nice oh cool sorry okay oh my gosh
this is great for me to watch white
people talk about sushi
it's my culture
you're using it to try to [ __ ] each
other
that's cool have you ever had
no Taiwanese ice cream shaved ice oh I
love it yeah so over there in the
airport area Asia town
my favorite Asian uh food there is
Taiwanese ice cream so good yes the
airport airport area culinary diversity
is
so uh where do you normally hang out
besides the airport
uh I live on the North side so okay the
domain yeah a lot of the domain uh
downtown Round Rock which is like
exploding so pretty yeah it is they
always do Christmas really well they
were doing it great last night all the
little lights it's really pretty and
there's parking everywhere it's really
it's really convenient yes but it's good
for 40 year olds you know
this guy's a very divorced dad he loves
exactly those are simple things in life
um yes Round Rock is great but do they
have the homeless that we have here
no didn't think so well yeah you know
back and forth you know they keep
changing the laws it sucks yeah it sucks
Julia how is the homeless situation in
San Antonio
it's not as bad as here oh it's they're
migrating that way as well but
it's not as bad as here yeah we're gonna
keep him going all the way to Round Rock
ruin uh the beautiful neighborhood over
there just kidding
the drive back and forth is just getting
crazy though like I remember when it was
like not to say like I remember but like
it used to be 45 50 minutes and now it's
an hour and a half yeah it's crazy it is
traffic traffic sucks old people
problems yeah the good old days are gone
yeah it's so easy
Jerry what's the what's the most
interesting thing about you
uh like give me like a category like
were you in Vietnam no I'm not that old
do you remember now I used to have the
mascot here at UT I was the longhorn
mascot for a couple oh uh missed the
Vince Young Rose Bowl by one year that
was in 2005. I did it in 03 and 04. so I
dressed up like a [ __ ] cow for two
years
it was a very good time the Texas
tradition yeah
what uh what do you think he used to be
the mascot is that sort of like he's on
the field he's like sort of an athlete
yeah a sort of an ass now we went to the
gym everybody was working out and the
cheerleaders they [ __ ] the earlier
person here and we're talking about the
cheerleaders they worked out those were
gymnasts and we're just falling on our
face yeah you're wearing a [ __ ]
costume yeah sweating our ass off yeah
that's awesome Julia what's the craziest
job that you had
I was a ski instructor in San Antonio oh
wow in Utah okay yeah Salt Lake City
area yes yes Park City it's beautiful
out there it is a bunch of kids
um that didn't know how to ski and so I
just basically had to make sure they
stood up all the way they fell I picked
them up made sure they peed said or
french fries yep yep so it was
interesting Jerry's Jerry's loving this
he is a really good list I suck I've
only done it twice but the time in my
life I could teach you oh I am or date
yeah second date definitely well wait
now hold on a second now what this is a
show I have to put a disclaimer out here
I'm on a real date too and with a
beautiful woman named Lucky and I have
to say this because she manifested this
she's been taught she's been trying to
get me up here she is I think she's
trying to yeah I think she's trying to
dump you dude yeah so I have to be real
I was I was gonna ask what number date
is this uh this is number first date
yeah wow yeah she kind of uh yeah she
can send me the link to it it seemed
really cool
did you take an edible too
I figured yeah she's the guilty party
here she gave them to me so you know wow
that's cool
I mean we're having a great time yeah so
sorry about that but I wanted to be real
and not ruin the date that I came here
on you know what I mean yeah
because she's beautiful and she's
amazing okay
she drugged you
share some with the rest of us
Jerry uh you're uh you're doing great
you're a very vivacious guy you've got a
lot of energy has this ever gotten you
into trouble have you ever like tried to
talk your way out of a speeding ticket I
sometimes I just can't stop talking I
have ADHD so like no way
I can be Super Hyper and you know not
bipolar quite but uh I can have like
spells where I'm just dead silent okay
well don't go there yeah
keep it positive but yeah Julia what do
you think about this mentally ill man
yes
being honest thank you vulnerable first
date yeah yeah he looks like you're good
a little a little like a healthy amount
of manic you know there's no need to
panic
um Jerry uh you look like you would do
really well cutting an infomercial could
you try to sell this stool that was
right behind you I mean I don't know
this one yeah just go go into your Billy
Mays voice no I don't think I could I
mean it's just so old oh my God no it's
it actually reminds me of the stools
that I grew up on with my mom so like
you know if you're into Nostalgia and if
you're like an elder Millennial and you
just want to remember that little white
you know matte plain uh painted table
this is uh one of the schools that have
been right under it you know let's go
back to Mom
this is a this is the kind of stools
that were around during 9 11. yeah
exactly I was in college when that
happened
and what did you do when you heard the
towers were hit
we stood still for like 10 [ __ ]
minutes it was crazy you know it was
just
you're like I was making copies in the
[ __ ] basement of the engineering
building I was just a little uh intern
there were you high on Edibles then too
no I didn't even know what those were
but yeah that was
burned into my brain yeah what a
horrible National Treasure no I was yeah
it took us yeah Julia what's your
experience with 911
I was two
okay so I don't remember
that doesn't have to stop you from being
a patriot
I am a patriot okay how have you
commemorated 911 in your life
oh I visited the new towers oh yeah
that's good
after it was all built
just okay that's that's fine
hopefully you paid some money to help
them with their whatever
um yeah any uh anything that you like to
tell her about 911
uh no uh the airports have sucked ever
since uh and that's about it yes yeah
back in the day you could go meet the
pilot oh it's so easy yeah so easy you
could hug him you could [ __ ] put him
in a little chokehold
I'm a little noogie yeah yeah
give him a little buggy uh Julia where
would you like to travel with Jerry what
do you what do you think he would do
well maybe like Italy the loud American
expressive yeah
you could go to Amsterdam get more
Edibles yeah I've always wanted to go
hey it's beautiful the windmills oh
the windows what color what color are
these windows Jerry yeah
did you do anything on bicycles yes
[Music]
yes the river
went to a park ate a lot drank a lot
yeah that's all that's all sounds like
Austin yeah we got hookers and Edibles
here
just kidding
um Jerry any anything you'd like to tell
Julia besides that you're on another
date
um no I I think you seem really cool and
um this has been fun uh
yeah
that's a lot yeah oh am I ending this am
I yeah
sure but no I'm having a good time this
is cool this is very cool
well thank you guys for coming on the
show give it up for Julia and Jerry
thank you guys
got a table full of Julius
that was a show thank you so much for
coming out anything you'd like to say
what do you think about the couples that
you saw tonight I liked everyone Bart
you're great Bart is still here he's
still there he's wow he's been watching
us silently the whole time I'm just
gonna blow up my car
um Cole she's great Cole was amazing she
was a call on the pole check her out on
Instagram everyone did really well I
think I got Julia Julia's still not out
of the closet no no I don't know what
they were up to
uh but we got the table of Julia's the
intermediaries the Consultants
some edibles and an orgy after the show
we got tario the amazing tario amazing
tario yeah look at you what a character
amazing
uh but yes check Rachel McMillan out on
princess pilot priests on Instagram
thank you guys he runs amazing shows in
Houston uh my name is Hans Kim thank you
guys so much for coming out drive safe
good night
thank you
thank you